[Musica]
da oltre vent'anni giro il mondo per
fare reportage per raccontare storie di
persone di luoghi deserti montagne
profondità del mare giungle c'è tanto da
raccontare nel pianeta e nel corso del
tempo ho visto questi luoghi cambiare
cambiare moltissimo e cambiare molto
rapidamente
naturalmente per colpa del riscaldamento
globale
allora ho deciso di raccontarlo questo
cambiamento ma di farlo in una maniera
un po diversa da quanto fanno tanti miei
colleghi nel mondo
non mi interessava tanto l'aspetto
apocalittico catastrofistico mi
interessava invece di più raccontare la
reazione del mondo raccontare le storie
di quei popoli che già oggi stanno
imparando a convivere con il cambiamento
vi si stanno adattando mi va di fare un
piccolo viaggio nel futuro
diciamo massimo tra il 2050 il 2100
ecco questa è un'immagine del pianeta
scattata da un satellite il satellite
sentinel 3 dell'agenzia spaziale europea
è una fotografia del pianeta scattata
nel giugno di quest'anno del 2019
guardate questi colori giallo giallo
giallo rosso rosso rosso accesissimo
faceva caldissimo giugno di quest'anno
ovunque nel mondo beh non poteva essere
altrimenti visto che abbiamo immesso
nell'atmosfera tanta co2 negli ultimi
decenni
per la precisione il 30 per cento in più
rispetto al passato dal 1970 ad oggi in
soli 40 anni meno di mezzo secolo
e allora facendo un rapido calcolo e
vedendo quello che ci dice la scienza un
ragazzo nato nel 2001 dal 2001 in poi
forse ce ne sarà qualcuno in sala
ha conosciuto nella sua vita soltanto un
mondo riscaldato non ha conosciuto il
mondo di ieri quello che conoscevo con
conosciuto io è quello che hanno che
avete conosciuto alcuni di voi infatti i
18 anni più caldi della storia del
pianeta da quando si rilevano le
temperature dell'atmosfera sono proprio
gli ultimi 18 anni e dunque succederanno
probabilmente tante cose da qui al 2100
pensiamo al mare l'italia è un paese che
è circondato per la gran parte dal mare
se veramente come sostengono gli
scienziati abbiamo ragione di credere
che appunto i loro studi sono da questo
punto di vista molto precisi entro il
2100 il mare dovesse alzarsi più o meno
tra 50 centimetri a un metro
l'italia potrebbe presentarsi così come
l'ha immaginata questo artista distopico
che si chiama martin bargis e che ha
disegnato una serie di tavole che
riprendono tutto il mondo nel 2100 come
lo vede lui ovviamente se l'italia si
presenta così altri paesi nel mondo
potrebbero addirittura scomparire tra
questi uno molto a rischio e l'olanda
sappiamo che si chiama anche paesi bassi
perché a circa la metà del proprio
territorio già oggi sotto il livello del
mare
quindi la sua grande sfida è quella di
rimanere a galla e che cosa sta facendo
l'olanda per rimanere a galla sta
facendo tante cose meravigliose tante
cose interessanti
una in particolare che è un po la
filosofia che innerva l'azione degli
olandesi e quella di re insegnare alla
natura a fare la natura loro hanno
capito che lì è il problema di tutto la
natura l'abbiamo violentata noi nel
corso dei secoli
adesso dobbiamo darle una mano dobbiamo
darle una stampella per tornare a fare
il suo lavoro chiamano questa filosofia
building uidne per costruire con la
natura
un esempio di questa filosofia è la
maniera che loro hanno trovato per
tenere lontano il mare dalle loro coste
e difendersi dalle tante tempeste
violente che arrivano
fermo dal mare del nord non costruendo
più di che gli olandesi sono famosi per
le dighe così come sono famosi per i
mulini a vento per gli zoccoli di legno
bene se guardassimo un'immagine
dall'alto dell'olanda vedremo tante di
queste dighe ma queste dighe sono dei
mostri di cemento e acciaio che messi e
piantati sul territorio cambiano per
sempre gli ecosistemi
allora gli olandesi questo l'hanno
capito e hanno immaginato un mondo
diverso per loro e per i loro figli un
mondo in cui invece di difendersi con le
dighe e la natura stessa che li
difenderà prendono il fango che dragano
dai loro porti porti molto importanti
hub commerciali dove arrivano navi anche
di grossissimo cabotaggio da tutto il
mondo
prendono questo fango lo sistemano in
certi punti della costa e aspettano che
la natura faccia il suo corso
questo fango verrà distribuito in
maniera equa lungo tutta la costa dalle
onde di marea esattamente immaginate
come voi al mattino spalmerete una fetta
di pane con della cioccolata solo che
invece della vostra mano col coltello e
la natura che fa tutto questo che fa il
lavoro per noi per difenderci
questo significa farsi difendere dalla
natura
naturalmente se il mare si alzerà e
qualcuno dovrà trasferirsi per forza
perché non potrà più vivere dove vive
si sta pensando anche a quello scenario
uno scenario in cui sempre in olanda in
questo caso a rotterdam
si comincia a pensare a delle case
galleggianti che non siano più sulla
terraferma ma che appunto volino
sull'acqua proprio come in questo
porticciolo in questa baia di rotterdam
e allora queste case che loro hanno
immaginato
oggi sono case che invece di essere
ricoperte da calotte pesanti di vetro
che creerebbero ancora di più un effetto
serra impressionante all'interno sono
ricoperte da un tessuto molto sottile
100 volte più sottile del vetro questo e
altre condizioni che loro sono riusciti
a creare fanno di queste case delle case
molto sostenibili che rimetteranno al
regime nell'atmosfera il 50 per cento di
co2 in meno rispetto ad una casa
canonica
una delle case dove probabilmente
abitate voi e mentre gli urbanisti
ingegneri gli architetti ripensano le
città e gli spazi urbani
c'è qualche altro visionario che pensa
che cosa mangeremo domani che un altro
grande tema da affrontare un'altra cosa
molto importante
sappiamo che tra qualche anno tra non
molti anni forse 30 40 saremo 11
miliardi di persone sulla terra da
sfamare e ci vorrà qualcosa da dare da
mangiare a questi 11 miliardi di persone
un signore di nome mark van rijsselberge
che vive nel nord dell'olanda sull'isola
detection ha messo in piedi la prima
soft farm del mondo sì esatto
la prima fattoria salata dove è in grado
di coltivare degli ortaggi usando
l'acqua del mare che gli entrava tutti i
giorni nella sua terra come ha fatto ci
ha messo del tempo è andato a caccia di
semi di specie che non si trovano più in
commercio disegni antichi semi che erano
abituati ad altri scenari e che chissà
perché le ragioni del commercio hanno
estromesso dal normale ciclo produttivo
ha preso questi semi li ha fatti
ibridare in laboratorio utilizzando le
tecniche e la conoscenza scientifica di
cui siamo in possesso lavorando con
delle università tante università nel
mondo fino a trovare quelle specie di
ortaggi che crescono bene con l'acqua
salata e adesso marca van rysselberghe
ha fatto dei brevetti che esporterà nel
mondo per la precisione in 60 paesi del
mondo e probabilmente non possiamo
ancora saperlo ma probabilmente grazie a
questi brevetti i popoli di questi 60
paesi del mondo che sono a particolare
rischio di inondazione di alluvioni
potranno avere qualcosa da mangiare
anche in caso di eventi estremi che
rovinino i loro raccolti
ma senza andare troppo lontano possiamo
rimanere anche più vicino a casa nostra
per capire che cosa stiamo facendo noi
in italia per adattarci che cosa
significa nel pratico adattarsi
convivere con il cambiamento climatico
non contrastarlo lottare che sono parole
e concetti vuoti perché abbiamo due
contendenti da una parte l'uomo
dall'altra la natura è uno scontro
asimmetrico non si può creare questo
scontro lui non combattiamo il
cambiamento climatico
noi tentiamo di abbracciarlo il
cambiamento climatico e allora in
calabria nella piana di sibari hanno
trovato un sistema molto valido per
risparmiare acqua
il problema della calabria ma in
generale il problema di tanti luoghi del
sud dell'italia
e proprio la carenza di acqua quella che
c'è va addossata perché un bene
preziosissimo e allora mettendo dei
piccoli sensori sulle foglie degli
alberi di ulivo questi sensori
immediatamente danno una serie di dati
importanti in particolare segnalano
subito se quelle foglie e quindi quelle
piante si stanno disidratando appena
arriva questo alert solitamente sullo
smartphone dell'agricoltore si azionano
immediatamente dei micro spruzzi che
vanno a colpire esattamente quelle
piante che si stanno disidratando per il
tempo che serve
di conseguenza il risparmio di acqua e
incredibile rispetto a quello che si
usava invece fino ad ieri
questo è un esempio di adattamento
ma non è l'unico perché la calabria come
tanti luoghi in italia sono luoghi molto
esposti al cambiamento climatico e
allora ci sono anche altre modalità di
confrontarsi col cambiamento climatico
non è detto che bisogna cedere di
schianto bisogna rassegnarsi
l'uomo non è fatto per rassegnarsi se
fosse stato così l'evoluzione si sarebbe
fermata 10 20 50 mila anni fa e non
saremmo qui oggi è invece appunto non è
così
in un altro posto della calabria in cui
in particolare nella zona di crotone nel
marchesato di crotone
la terra è molto arida c'è un altro
grave problema di cui forse avrete
sentito parlare anche se no
sicuramente nella maniera corretta c'è
un problema di desert illazione
non mi sono sbagliato non parlo di
desertificazione la desertificazione se
la sentirete vuol dire un'altra cosa
la desert illazione vuol dire che si
inaridisce il terreno diventa un terreno
non più produttivo e allora questi
calabresi cosa fanno
hanno trovato il modo di fare quella che
si chiama la minima lavorazione cioè
passano con dei gli aratri molto sottili
lievemente il primo primissimo strato
della terra per non andare a intaccare i
nutrienti gli strati ancora fertili che
ci sono più in basso e sono già messi a
dura prova dalla carenza di acqua dalla
carenza di piogge dalle temperature
altissime
così facendo loro ancora presidiano dei
territori importantissimi per l'italia
dei territori dove civili ancora gente
dove si deve ancora produrre
naturalmente se loro volessero
potrebbero andar via da lì ma questo
significherebbe che in poco tempo quei
territori morirebbero diventerebbero
un'unica enorme distesa di argilla bene
ma non sono gli unici a presidiare i
loro territori quelli che lavorano sul
territorio desertico ci sono anche
quelli che invece lavorano ancora nel
verde e nella natura ancora in calabria
in questo caso nel golfo di scilla ci
sono dei luoghi molto belli molto
interessanti sono dei vigneti sono dei
vigneti abbarbicati letteralmente alle
pareti rocciose che sono a picco sul
mare di scilla bellissimi a vedersi
incredibilmente difficili da curare
per chi cura quei luoghi non a caso li
chiamano vigneti eroici e pensate c'è
gente che crede ancora talmente nel
proprio lavoro e crede talmente che la
natura possa riprendere il sopravvento
che non abbandona quei posti ma
piuttosto ha costruito dei piccoli
trenini a cremagliera che vanno in
salita da un filare all'altro per
permettergli tutto l'anno la cura del
vigneto e ovviamente quando è il tempo
anche la vendemmia
anche questo e adattamento
e parliamo di roccia parliamo di roccia
qui abbarbicato alla natura ma nella
roccia
forse potrebbe essere iscritta una
famosa frase pensata e citata dal insim
edinson che era un professore un docente
universitario della louisiana state
university di baton rouge nel 1963
quindi non tanto tempo fa 50 anni fa
mackinson disse la famosa frase che la
specie che sopravviverà al cambiamento
non è la specie più forte ma quella in
grado di adattarsi forse l'avrete
sentita questa frase ed è stata una
frase per tanto tempo attribuita in
maniera errata a darwin ma non l'ha
detta darwin era il professor mag hinson
che commentando l'origine della specie
uno dei testi più importanti scientifici
ma iscritti appunto di cui fu autore
charles darwin ebbe a commentare cosi ea
dare forza a questo concetto di
adattamento succedeva 50 anni fa ma
adattamento è una parola che non deve
evocare rassegnazione non vuol dire che
se ci adattiamo non combattiamo più la
nostra guerra per tenere bassa la co2
catturarla dall'atmosfera quella è una
guerra che continueremo a combattere
quella sì che è una guerra l'adattamento
non lo è l'adattamento evoca
lungimiranza e una parola dura difficile
perché prevede che noi scendiamo in
campo quotidianamente che noi cambiamo
le nostre abitudini quotidiane
adattamento non fa sconti a nessuno
adattamento siamo ognuno di noi
ecco perché questa parola prima di
essere sdoganata alla comunità mondiale
di essere accettata ha impiegato
tantissimo tempo almeno 20 anni era il
97 quando si discuteva il protocollo di
kyoto ve lo ricorderete sicuramente in
quel momento si cominciò a parlare di
adattamento ma questa parola è stata
schiacciata sotto il tacco della
politica e sotto il tacco della scienza
per tanto tempo ci dicevano se parliamo
di adattamento è finita non è vero non è
vero perché la natura è stata più veloce
di quello che ci immaginassimo e quindi
come vediamo ogni giorno della nostra
vita
il climate change c'è già e noi siamo
costretti ad adattarci ma lo facciamo
perché nella natura umana
adattarsi e allora il mio staff ed io
abbiamo deciso di raccontarlo questo
adattamento con un web doc che ne porta
il nome
adaptation abbiamo voluto girare il
mondo raccontare storie parlare con le
persone comuni con gli scienziati con i
politici con chiunque sia oggi
protagonista di questo adattamento
perché crediamo fortemente che i giovani
non debbano limitarsi soltanto a
scendere nelle piazze per if riders for
fiducia ma debbano usare la scienza
usarla per correggere gli errori
commessi nel passato dalle generazioni
precedenti
proprio come sta facendo in olanda
all'università di delft una giovane
ricercatrice italiana che è il capo
della mad motor che è la pianura di
fango che sta salvando le coste olandesi
e allora probabilmente da qualche parte
nel cosmo ci può essere un pianeta b ma
credo che forse quello che abbiamo
riusciamo ancora a salvarlo grazie
[Applauso]